à l'origine une feuille de papier et
c'est tout enfin presque il faut aussi
beaucoup de dextérité d'imagination et
un bon sens de la géométrie
sébastien lime et est un sculpteur de
papier c'est d'ailleurs comme ça qu'il a
commencé c'est la naissance de mes deux
enfants raphaël et nora qui m'ont amené
à me tourner vers le ring m
j'avais un côté destructeur au niveau de
ses sculptures là je crois que l'origami
les enfants m'ont reconstruit et puis
j'ai trouvé la bonne balance au niveau
artistique
la douceur de ces origami le fait vite
connaître dans le monde entier il a déjà
fait le tour de l'europe grâce à ses
créations
et on peut aujourd'hui tentés de
l'imiter de donner vie à ses plus beaux
modèles des animaux notamment sébastien
lime et à une formation de naturalistes
l'environnement et son thème de
prédilection comme le fait que ont créé
des pollutions
et qu'on peut lui la mère et
par exemple avec ses masques
actuellement on en a on en a énormément
besoin de ces masques mais une fois
qu'on les a portés la plupart du temps
on commence à les retrouver par terre
et voilà je me suis amusé à essayer de
recycler les miens l'origami anar un
exutoire mais aussi donc un vecteur de
messages et depuis quelque temps
l'artiste s'amuse à aller au devant du
public il dépose ses pliages dans la rue
mon idée c'était de montrer que
l'origami est un art et de le montrer au
grand public est la plus belle galerie
qui existe c'est la rue donc finalement
c'est comme ça que je me suis mis à les
allées déposer sa dans la rue comme des
comme des cadeaux un petit peu pour pour
essayer de deux mètres de mettre un peu
de gaieté dans un endroit
ses oeuvres sont cachées à marc bouet à
châteaudun et même hors de notre région
alors ouvrez bien grand les yeux
l'origami à plein de facettes